It's great to see so many people out and beautiful Cornish morning here at Land's End and a very special moment for everybody.
It was an amazing moment and they're just proud to cooperate when involved with bringing the Olympics here.
Hopefully this can build up throughout the country and that's one of the great things about the torch,...
...it gives everyone the chance to feel a part of the olympics and really build that up to the games.
Accepting the flame off Ben Ainslie was one of the best things that ever happened to me.
To be part of something that you couldn't ever imagine that you were gonna take part in,...
...and here you are at Land's End, holding this torch, it's just remarkable.
The only way to describe it is like a carnival act: everyone's happy, everyone's chanting, everywhere I look there are children with...
...homemade torches that they've made at home or in the classroom.
And for me that sums up what the torch relay is all about.
It's a huge privilege, a massive honor.
Four, three, two, one.